[Music]
ever since the end of the Second World
War
Tories have had an uneasy relationship
with Europe though the most famous
statesman they've ever had was a fan we
hope we're men of every country will
think as much of being a European and
belonging to their native land it was
almost three decades before another
conservative Prime Minister Edward Heath
signed us up to what was then the
European Economic Community but even
some of those who supported it at the
time and later became cabinet ministers
regret doing so now Ted Heath House of
Commons and I think the majority of six
John not served in mrs. Thatcher's
government she likened herself to one of
history's bloodiest war mongers in a
speech about Europe in Europe if you
believe some of the things said and
written about my views on Europe it must
seem rather like inviting Genghis Khan
to speak on the virtues of peaceful
coexistence no it's been like this for
20 odd years at least and I mean for 150
odd years Jeff Evans spends his life
studying the ebb and flow of British
politics the oxford university professor
says if our electoral system was more
like Europe then both labour and the
Tories might squabble less about Europe
within each party you've got at least
two parties struggling to get out if
we're in Europe and we adopt to save
this standard PR system that almost
every country in Europe has then split a
long time ago I think they need about
more coherent parties but more of them
John Major calls some in his own cabinet
bastards as he wrangled with the
Maastricht Treaty in 1993 one of those
who voted against it from outside the
cabinet was Bill cash
who still has issues with Europe what
John Major did was to allow by treaty
the creation of European government that
was the biggest mistake of all because
it was it was inconsistent with the
British people being able to make the
decisions for themselves in general
elections on a whole range of issues the
creation of European government was a
catastrophic mistake will brexit
whatever form it takes bridge the
conservative divides over Europe once
and for all
don't hold your breath Dairy Boden Sky
News in Oxfordshire